[Music]
hey you guys time for another book
review this is another novel that came
recommended on the kindle unlimited uh
subscription that i have it was just one
of you know many that sort of came up
that you could read for free that was
kind of similar to ones that i had read
before
and this is a novel called winterset
holo
now i believe this is this is uh the
debut novel of a guy named jonathan
edward durham this book came out back in
september of
2021. now interestingly i looked um a
little bit like i just kind of skimmed
uh the author's bio and interestingly
he's from philadelphia
and he actually started out uh he got a
degree in neuroscience and did a lot of
uh did work in that area but then he was
just kind of like well i think i'd
rather be a writer which i get it it's
really funny this is like apropos
nothing but it was just like i was on
goodreads and i was like just out of
curiosity to see like what other people
thought of this book like after i
finished it
and the first review like on the first
page of goodreads is from him like the
author and he says because it's like a
five-star rating he's like um i didn't
mean to accidentally like
rate my own book five stars lol and then
he's like and then i felt the deed to
like come on here and make a brit review
like to explain myself uh and he called
like the inside of his head an anxiety
volcano and again i was just kind of
like i feel you i feel you on that as
well so he just seems like a really just
from that brief exchange he just seemed
like a really funny like nice dude and
uh you know from what i've seen of like
other people that
kind of know a little bit more about him
like he seems like a really nice dude
so this book this is really interesting
i don't think that this is normally
something that i would have picked up
necessarily because it's kind of more
dark fantasy than hor oh it's definitely
horror i'm not saying that um it goes
like full-on [ __ ] gory violent horror
like toward the end
but it also has like a dark fantasy
thing and like i said i didn't
when i when i find a book like on kindle
unlimited i'm just kind of like oh that
cover looks cool or i like the title or
something or it's like an author that
i've read their stuff before and it's
like i really liked it i don't usually
read the synopsis um or anything other
than maybe like the first sentence
because i like to go into things like
not knowing
what it's about
and so i'm kind of glad that i didn't
read the synopsis of this because i
might not because like i said it's kind
of more dark fantasy which isn't usually
my thing i do read some like that but
it's not usually the first thing that i
would pick i'm more kind of into you
know haunted houses or psychological
horror or slashers you know stuff like
that so
so i'm really glad that i didn't really
look into what this book was about
before i read it because i really didn't
have much of an idea where it was going
and it was just like and it turned out
being like really really cool
so
here's okay
anything i say about this book like i
said i i feel like i say this on a lot
of my reviews but
if you don't want to know anything about
this book i knew like literally nothing
about this book other than like the
title and the fact that there's like a
little bunny on the cover
and
that's it uh i just decided i was gonna
read it just dove right in and i liked
that because again i had no idea where
the [ __ ] this thing was gonna go and i
was just kind of like oh okay this is
happening this is okay i'm rolling with
this and it's like and i ended up really
really liking it
so if you don't want to know anything
about it then obviously you can't watch
this but
if you need me to
pitch it for you a little bit
before you get into it
imagine
a mashup
of this is gonna sound bizarre but this
is exactly what this reminded me of
imagine a mashup
of winnie the pooh
and watership down
crossed with the most dangerous game
okay
that's pretty much the three things that
kept
coming into my head like while i was
reading this if that sounds good to you
then that's pretty much exactly what
this book is uh so you will probably
really dig it
so here's the setup uh our main
character is a guy named eamon buckley
he's kind of like a younger guy
now they don't go a huge amount into his
background but there is enough to kind
of like get a picture of it
so apparently he grew up with only his
dad like that's the only other person
that he knew for like the first i
believe was 12 years or 14 years of his
life because his dad is kind of one of
those dudes that just like lives out in
the woods like off the grid and they
grew all their own food or hunted for
all their own food
and the dad was kind of like
you know kind of one of those like i
said prepper paranoid type of dudes and
he's just like there's no reason for you
to go out into the world it sucks and
you know there's no there's nobody out
there you know worth talking to but me
you know there's nothing out there worth
looking at but this so you might as well
just stay here
so he's lived this really isolated uh
life just out in the woods
now
when he's about i think it's when he's
about 14 years old like i said this
isn't gone into in any great detail they
just kind of like mention it at varying
points during the story
at some point when i think he's 14 years
old his dad
kind of like packs up some stuff
and
he's like yeah um
here's all the stuff let's make sure you
know how to punt and do all the traps
and everything like that see ya he
doesn't necessarily say that he's never
coming back but he never comes back
uh so basically this 14 year old kid is
kind of left out there in the woods at
which point uh it seems like the you
know child protective services becomes
involved and they take him to an
orphanage and then he ends up with a
foster family who again they don't
really go a lot into it but he ends up
like really hating the foster family and
like running away from them and stuff
like that
but what the upshot of all this is is
that at this point uh eamon buckley uh
you know like i said he doesn't know uh
anything about his mother he never met
her he never met any other family
members the only person he knew was his
dad and he didn't even actually know
what his real first name was until he
went into the system and like all the
legal stuff came up
so
he was having like a lot of struggles
during his teenage years and it happened
that somebody sent him this book called
winterset holo by a guy named edward
addington
and he credits this book
with essentially saving his life because
he's like there was something about this
book that really like
made me understand maybe my place in the
world
the book winner set hollow the book
within a book um and actually there is
there are passages because the book is
um you know the book inside the book
winner said hollow inside the actual
book winner said hello if that makes any
sense is actually kind of like it's all
written in verse
and it's basically a story as i said
kind of like watership down or kind of
like winnie the pooh where it's like all
of these anthropomorphic animal
characters
and with different personalities and
proclivities and things like that and
they all live in a place called
winterset hollow and they have this
thing every year
called barley day which is like their
big like feast celebration that they
have annually and it kind of goes into
you know them preparing for this big
feast and like the personalities uh
within
so
this book really struck a chord with him
and he read it many many times
and it's really as i said kind of helped
him sort of like get his [ __ ] together
so in the present day uh i think he's
meant to be like 19 20 21 somewhere like
that
he's kind of uh you know a very shy
person as i said the first part of his
life you know he didn't know anyone
other than his father so he doesn't have
a lot of social graces but
um he has actually managed to befriend
uh his two best friends who are a couple
and their names are caroline and mark
and so the first part of the book is
kind of just their fun like interactions
with one another which is actually
really fun because i actually did like
these three characters they worked
really well together
so caroline uh is also really into this
winter set hollow book
mark uh seems like he doesn't really
give a [ __ ] he's but he's he knows that
they're into it but he likes to kind of
like make fun of him about it because
his big thing is like oh i'm so dumb and
it's like i don't do this he's not
really that dumb but that's kind of like
the dynamics they're always like picking
on him for being dumb and he kind of
thinks it's funny so he's just kind of
like this stupid book and i can't
believe blah blah blah but he's just you
know browsing them like friends do
so at the near the beginning of the
story um all of them get these coupons
they're given them by somebody at a
bookstore or something like that this
all takes place in like the pacific
northwest by the way washington state
so they get these coupons and the
coupons are good for
uh one ferry ride
over to addington isle now addington
isle is this little bitty island
off the coast of washington state where
edward addington had his estate and
where winterset hollow was written
now
edward addington was
from a very very wealthy family so the
house that he built on this is a mansion
and there's like all kind of crazy like
he had these massive parties there like
back in the 20s and stuff like that so
all of that stuff is kind of still there
but it's been abandoned or so everyone
thinks uh for a really long time
so caroline mark and eamon they get
these coupons and they're gonna go
uh take this ferry and they're gonna do
this little tour of this island which
apparently happens every year because
coupons get given out because as i said
this book inside the book winter set
hollow is much like winnie the pooh is
kind of like you know beloved on a
worldwide scale and has like a huge
amount of fans even though edward
addington has been uh dead for quite a
while
so they're good so they're gonna go out
there and so they go on the ferry and
there's like a handful of other people
like other super fans of edward
addington they're very jazzed about this
as well and they're super jazz because
the date that they're going out there is
the same date as barley day the feast
celebration in the book that they all
love so much
so the first part of the book um i did
see that some people thought the build
up was kind of slow but i didn't really
mind that um i was just enjoying
spending time with the characters and
them kind of you know because the
characters the three at the uh you know
the forefront or the center of it are
actually really really likable so i
actually really kind of liked their kind
of you know just joshing with each other
and stuff like that like while they're
on the way over there
so they get to like this guy named
captain jean
takes him out on this rickety-ass uh
boat to this island
and they go they all go there and
basically they're like they're not
allowed to tour the house or anything
really um you just kind of they all
wanted to go there to just kind of like
drink in the atmosphere of their hero
like this guy that wrote this book that
they all love
now it so happens though that while
they're on the island
uh captain gene uh kind of gets sort of
drunk and sort of passes out uh a big
huge storm comes along
and
mark and caroline and eamon sort of
wander off
and they notice because they're you know
everyone's just kind of like walking
around the island wanting to look at
stuff you can see the house but it's
like off in the distance and there's
like a gate that's locked and everything
so they kind of wander off and then they
notice that part of the fence around the
back
is uh has been kind of uh taken down by
like a tree that fell
and so they're just kind of like well
[ __ ] i mean you know no one's supposed
to be here and it's like we came all
this way so let's go out here and like
check out the house like get up closer
to it like you can see some of the
grounds and stuff because like i said
this is like an estate there's a mansion
there's this cra they find like all this
weird stuff like
there's this one thing that's like uh
almost like a gazebo i want to i
pictured it kind of like a gazebo or
like a big like raised
platform and it had like all these chess
boards like around like a sundial like
clockwork and then there's like a big
cage in the middle almost as though
someone was had to be trapped in the
cage and was like playing all these
other people like at chess and there's
even stuff left over from like old
parties and you know there's like
martini glasses and [ __ ] like that
because like i said all the rich elite
used to come out there and party on this
island
so they're kind of wandering around
looking at all that stuff and then they
go up to the house
and they notice that there is it's
starting to get dark because of the
storm and everything and then they
notice that there looks like there's
kind of like a flickering light like
inside the house and they're like what
the [ __ ] like nobody's supposed to be in
there
and then at that point like i said and
this is spoiler spoiler spoiler like i
said if you don't want anything to do
like know anything about this book i
won't spoil like the whole end and
everything but this part was kind of
like a part where i was just like holy
[ __ ] okay that's where this book is
going um i think some of the synopses of
the book actually do
you know say what it's about so i don't
think i'm really spoiling anything that
you know
earth-shattering but
so yeah so they think somebody's inside
the house and they're kind of like
trying to look in there at which point
the door opens
and
an anthropomorphic talking rabbit
comes out and starts talking to them
this rabbit is runny mead rabbit who is
one of the characters
in the winters that hollow book
uh he looks
old uh he's got one leg missing so he's
got like a peg leg one of his ears is
all [ __ ] up and it's like wrapped up
in a scarf uh and he but he seems like a
nice
dude a nice bunny
and uh he's basically like well hey you
guys you know i just obviously that
eamon is just like can't [ __ ] believe
it which is what would happen like you
see you'd open a door and a big [ __ ]
rabbit comes out and it's like hey bro
what's up you know what i mean so uh so
yeah so he passes out and goes so then
it turns out
all of them come inside the house uh
eamon is unconscious for several hours
uh and then he comes too and then he
talks to uh runny mead rabbit
and basically the upshot of it is
all of the characters from edward
addington's book winterset holo are
real like as in they are
uh anthropomorphic
animals they can talk they can walk they
can act like humans except they're
animals so the main ones are runny maid
rabbit is the main guy and then there is
also flackwell who is a frog and he's
like a chef
and uh there's also binghamton or bing
uh the bear who is mute but he has this
big hammer he's a builder
the builder bear
and then there is finn or phineas the
fox who is the hunter
so these four characters uh essentially
invite eamon and his two friends as well
as all the other people that were on the
boat
uh to join them in their barley day
feast uh flackwell frog is like one of
the best chefs on earth apparently like
according to uh you know everything that
everybody says and he makes this massive
feast and all this other stuff now
you will note that this is as i said
this is a horror novel so you pretty
much know that this can't be
quite as awesome as it all seems
and you know
something that somehow [ __ ] is gonna go
bad and indeed it does it goes very
very very bad uh and
massive carnage ensues
and that's kind of all i want to spoil
because there's a whole bunch of other
stuff going on about
why the animals are there where they
came from
uh what was the deal with edward
addington uh and his house um and it's
just kind of this really it's kind of
like a layered examination too of
and one of the kind of running themes
throughout the book is sort of like
don't ever meet your heroes type of
situation because eamonn had pretty much
uh based i don't know if he'd if i'd say
he based his whole identity around this
book but he was saying this book you
know pretty much saved my life and made
me feel that i had a place in the world
and then for him to find out that it
wasn't that it absolutely was not what
he thought and that edward addington the
author was absolutely not what he
thought um is really kind of like a a
really horrifying like revelation for
him so there's a lot of that kind of
going through there everyone kind of
dealing with their own stuff and even
though the animals
turn out essentially to be the
antagonists but you know
where they're coming from too and you
can kind of like feel sorry for them
because their whole history is kind of
like laid out as well
so there's that too now as i said this
is dark fantasy but it does go in a very
it's very gory and it's very violent
toward the end now some people uh
complained that the writing was too i
believe a word that was used uh several
times was florid
i can see that but it didn't really
bother me um it just depends the the
writing is very
dense very flowery um not to an extent
where you're just kind of like knock it
off but so if that's not something you
like if you like your writing style kind
of more terse and unadorned uh then
probably this might try your patience a
little bit i don't really mind it um you
know i don't mind that style it's very
descriptive like i said it's very
flowery and you know he goes a lot into
like when they do the barley day feast
he goes all into like all the different
foods and stuff like that but honestly i
didn't mind that because it really this
thing i mean this book really painted a
picture in my head and a lot of books do
that but this one was like really vivid
i mean i could really see the way he
described the inside of the manor house
and the way he was describing this feast
and the way he described the characters
was just really really vivid and i could
just kind of see it and i was thinking
to myself god this would make a great
movie you know what i mean i think it
would make a really really good movie i
don't know if anybody would want to see
it because it's a weird like i said it's
a little bit of a weird genre crosser i
want to say um there might have been
other things like this this gave me very
much the same kind of vibe as some of
like
the darker
children's entertainment like i said
like from the 80s maybe like you know
what secret of nim or like i said um or
never ending story or something like
that like some of jim henson stuff like
labyrinth or the dark crystal
things like that so if you dug that kind
of stuff but want to see it more like
overtly horror like i said the end of it
or the second half of it goes very much
in a most dangerous game type of
direction
um and it's very very violent and very
gory like people get dispatched in
really really horrible ways uh so
there's that so if that sounds like
something that you would be into then
you'll probably really really dig this
it's i don't really think that i've read
anything quite like this like with this
particular combination so i'm really
glad
that i didn't read the synopsis i'm not
saying that i wouldn't have necessarily
read it if i'd read the synopsis first
but
i don't know because it's more dark
fantasy maybe i'd have been like um you
know maybe i'll read that later i'll put
it off or whatever but because i didn't
know anything about it and i just liked
the title and the cover looked cool with
the bunny on it it's because i was kind
of thinking i was like oh maybe it's
like folk horror you know
because it kind of looks like a folk or
thing and i was just like all right i'm
into that and uh so i might not have
read it until later but i'm glad that i
actually didn't read the synopsis and i
read it now because this was actually uh
quite awesome so if that sounds like
something that you would be into if you
have kindle unlimited you can read it
for free or if you would like to
buy the paperback and support the author
you may do that as well i believe he's
an independent author uh two his name is
jonathan edward durham and i believe his
first novel so
let me know if you've read it or if it
sounds good and you want to read it um
you know and we'll have a discussion
about it in the comments and that'll do
it for this tomes of terror i will see
you guys on the next one bye